the world is pretty evenly divided those
that live in rural areas and those that
live in cities but how do people decide
which of these two will be the right fit
for them and make them happy in a place
even make you happy
I dove into research to see who's
happier this study says that rural
people are less depressed but then this
book shows how cities make people
happier then again this study concludes
rural dwellers are actually happier so
what's the truth we asked people in Los
Angeles about their happiness well we're
here on the streets of Los Angeles the
big city talking to people about
happiness first question are you happy I
mean I feel like I'm not that happy when
I'm in the city well I'm actually moving
like I'm kind of not happy here are you
happy any other we're very happy yeah
are you happy uh sometimes let me say
all the time sometimes so after those
mixed answers we headed out to the
country stopping at the halfway house
cafe for good old-fashioned food and a
chat about happiness song you're with
Sandy hello are you from around here yes
I've lived here 30 years Cindy are you
happy yes there have it are you happy
absolutely yeah absolutely right there
are you happy yeah oh well great happy
the rural people did seem happier but
was there happiness actually connected
to living in the country we have some of
the same people if they thought location
affected their happiness do you have a
lot of like hometown pride yeah I do I
went to school here my kid went to
school here yeah I know all these people
yeah this is this is my life this is my
town do you feel like you'd be happier
you know a rural environment I love the
country but the cities you bring
everything you can go to the country not
to leave it I don't really like going to
the city at all what what there's a what
things make you happy I do a lot of
exercise outdoors so I mean it just
helps me relax and I feel like those
things make me happy so it's not really
a debate between rural and city life
people that are happy are often just a
match to their homes this actually makes
sense because the Gallup Healthways
well-being index has liking where you
live is one of the five main indexers
for overall well-being so if you like
where you live you could be one step
closer to happiness
Shh